après la grève du 19 janvier contre la
réforme des retraites les syndicats
appellent à une nouvelle mobilisation
massive ce mardi conséquence de
nombreuses perturbations sont à prévoir
dans les transports plusieurs lignes
seront impactées comptez intrins sur
trois pour la ligne u un sur 10 pour la
ligne N la ligne J et la ligne L les RER
A et B seront également perturbés les
syndicats de l'éducation seront
également mobilisés ce mardi le 19
janvier 62% des écoles étaient grévistes
dans le primaire les syndicats de
l'éducation et des lycéens ont appelé
dans un communiqué commun à un mouvement
encore plus fort pour le 31 janvier du
côté de la santé la CGT santé et actions
sociales annoncent continuer la
mobilisation ce mardi 31 janvier ce
lundi 30 janvier l'Inter syndical
départemental était réunies devant la
préfecture des Yvelines à Versailles
pour rencontrer le préfet l'objectif de
cette rencontre symbolique faire
remonter les revendications locales à
l'échelle nationale
c'est pas au niveau de départemental que
ça se décide en revanche le préfet en
tant que grand commis de l'État est
fondée à recevoir nos réclamations et à
entendre notre détermination et à la
faire remonter à au gouvernement parce
que l'idée c'est qu'effectivement
partout dans les départements en plus de
cette internation de cette intercer
syndicale nationale en plus du travail
dans les secteurs les fédérations etc il
y a un travail dans les territoires pour
montrer que l'opposition à la réforme
des retraites elle est résolue elle
s'encre au niveau local profondément
l'occasion également de montrer l'union
entre les différents syndicats il
fallait qu'on montre aujourd'hui aux
habitants de des Yvelines que les
syndicats étaient tous ensemble et je
voulais aussi nous voulions aussi que le
préfet sache que tous les syndicats
étaient bien là ensemble aujourd'hui
c'est également ensemble qu'il se
rendront mardi à Paris dans les Yvelines
des bus sont prévues pour rejoindre le
départ du cortège notamment à
Rambouillet et à Mantes-la-Jolie une
mobilisation qui devrait perdurer des
descentes aux flambeau unitaires sont
organisés le 3 février dans de
nombreuses villes Yvelines